[Music]
welcome to this
special edition of cosmic queries star
talk
for it we are in collaboration with a
conference being held a live conference
being held by pocket lab which is an
organization that serves the needs of
science teachers around the world
with demos and materials and literature
and so they hosted a conference and we
star talk were invited to do a live
cosmic queries
for their audience during this covid
separated conference
thousands and thousands of teachers
tuned in for it
so we invite you to sit back and enjoy
cosmic queries with pocket lab
let's just start off with uh abby gandhi
she's coming to us from ottawa
i hope she's in the room with us now how
can we encourage curiosity in all
students given
our and their limited resources and time
in this coming year
so uh this seems to be a theme that's
running throughout all the questions the
fact that we're learning remotely
and that you know over digital platforms
and that type of stuff but
you know that notwithstanding how do you
encourage um curiosity
yeah so i i don't have a silver bullet
there but what i
do know and i've said this before that
kids
obviously we have kindergarten through
upper high school represented among the
teachers
and children students are different at
each of these
stages i get that i can tell you and you
certainly know those who teach
kindergarten and first through fifth
grades
that curiosity is just a built-in
feature
of what it is to be a kid and so i think
for me the task of teachers
is not so much how to stimulate
curiosity but how to not
squash the curiosity that's already
there
and that's a different task right
because if you know it's already there
then you can nurture it you can bring in
elements tools
methods that continue to stimulate it
so that the child never knows a day
without being curious about one thing or
another
and one thing i know that squashes
curiosity and i get it it's got to be a
part of the curriculum i get it
that you got to sort of hand kids
information that you then test them on
later
i get that but there's got to be some
room either
built in or you pry it open to
put things out in front of the students
for which there is no obvious answer
and they say well i wonder how you get
the answer to that how do i
dig and you know it's it's easy to give
the example when you're in a in a
in a yard and there's grass and there
might be some flowers or leaves or a
tree
and you're poking around nature but
curiosity can manifest in practically
any discipline
and and artists know that you just give
a a
a you know a canvas and and paint
in it and give it to kids they'll just
start painting right
that's a that's an act of exploration
that that you are not
guiding all you're doing is providing
the tools and let that creativity
unfold because for me curiosity and
creativity
go together they're basically the same
word when you're a student coming up
through the system
so i think if you devote some fraction
of a curriculum
to just exploring rather than being
theirs i'm the one with the answers and
you
take notes because you'll be tested on
it later
um try to find ways to put out
even questions that you know the answer
to but they require a little bit of
exploration
you know um what did happen
if it's a history class what did happen
when napoleon um
tried to conquer russia well hmm
i looked at the let's look at the
weather for moscow
in december all right oh it's 20 below
it's this
it's snow hmm but now napoleon thought
about that let's let's investigate this
you can hand them the answers or you can
collectively find the answers together
and for me that's the difference between
learning by being taught and learning by
doing
and fulfilling your own curiosity and
that would be a way to sustain it
for the youngest of kids they already
have it i already have it i love that
so kind of reverse engineering um
the learning process you start with the
answer and work your way backwards
um well so you well that's another way
to do that right
but sometimes you don't know what the
answer could or should be
okay and even if the answer is known if
you're learning
you can treat it like it's a brand new
kind of exploration
of what would you do if you were
napoleon no i would have checked out the
weather
for forecasts right yeah
exactly check the weather okay
for the french revolution you know are
people eating
or are they not right exactly are you
paying attention
and did they pay attention was there
enough cake was there enough cake
how good were the bakers
so uh if you treat something that may
even be known as an unknown right that
is that's a point of curiosity for
everybody and then you then everyone
stimulates their thoughts and their
ideas and then you go to what actually
happened
then you can criticize or complement
what actually happened
so that's an example not even drawn from
the sciences but
you know keeping this multidisciplinary
as an educational task
and as so many teachers need to think
about so
yeah all right man great answer great
answer so what else you got bring it up
i got alan here um is there a last name
where they from or yes yes thanks neil
thanks this is alan
wasmoen from omaha okay stop pronouncing
last name
nevermind
allen was so it was so simple neil with
alan
take a collection right help chuck reed
exactly alan knows who he is
anyway allen says this uh we hear a lot
about anti-science folks in the united
states
how do we restore science to its proper
status among
the general populace so is
is there anything that you can do
to create a greater respect
for science especially in light of our
leaders
and i'm not being political but out our
leaders
i'm not but but they they tend to poo
poo
science i mean you have a number of
governors who
are defying their public health
um officials you have people saying
don't wear masks you have people say
and so this this has got to have a
deleterious effect
on the way people view science so i
again i don't have a silver bullet here
i think
here's the answer i don't want to give
but i'm going to start with it
i wish i didn't have to give this answer
because i don't like this answer
but it could actually work is if
every science research program
came with a fraction of its budget for
advertising
and you just advertise what science is
doing for you
in your everyday life in because science
is there in ways that we all
take for granted oh my gosh how many
people are
did not die in childbirth who are alive
today
simply because advances in medical
science thanks science
thank you so you would you would just
every day you'd see a public service
announcement here's what science
does for you right and this here's what
led to that discovery
oh you you used you you had an mri
measurement today
where did that come from it came from
this physicist who got a nobel prize for
that discovery
did he care about how your health no he
cared about molecules in space
and won the nobel prize that piece of
information
got picked up by a medical technologist
and became a machine that diagnoses your
health
a reminder of this and
yes it's advertised i hate advertising
because it's always designed to make you
do what you don't want to do
but if it's a public service
announcement every day
maybe that would have some influence
just maybe i'm tired of hearing people i
don't like the space program
oh let me find out what the weather is
for next week on my satellite tv
right you know and people have lost
track
of what role science innovative science
engineering and technology play
in not only their their their health
their wealth their security but just in
how whether or not they can enjoy
life and so um so there needs to be a
better marketing plan and that's the
answer i don't
want to give let me give another answer
that's directly related to our audience
today which is 10 000 science teachers
around the world i think and i'm just
putting this out there i think if some
portion of your curriculum
were devoted to teaching science
not as information but as a way
of querying nature okay we tinted on
this in
developing and curating curiosity
but think about it if you learn what
science is and how and why it works
then you're not going to grow up and say
oh i just
trust science or what those scientists
are
telling me because you will understand
what it is where it's coming from that
there's an experiment
there are observations that have been
confirmed
that led to research results that are
arriving at these conclusions
you'll understand the entire anatomy of
that
understanding of that the anatomy of
those statements that are getting made
and i'll give you a real good example of
this at the beginning of the coronavirus
where it's rising in the united states
early march
um it was like wear masks don't wear a
mask there was there was there was
seemed like there was conflicting
information you know why there's
conflicting information
because at any given moment you plug in
all the information you have
the information you have at any given
moment for a new and novel virus
you're gathering it you want to know it
immediately you want to wait to six
months
for all of these things so we're giving
you this as it comes across
and kind of in real time and then we
find out no this is not working
do this okay what i'm saying is
yes that was changing because new
information was informing it
it wasn't changing because well let's
try something else i don't know no
new data was informing it and that's how
science works
okay i'm sorry i'm screaming at you oh
man i like it i love i love the passion
i like the past that's how science works
and you're like the samuel l jackson of
science
right now just angry with everything
so that's science again
to my face so
so if that's how science works then
you'll understand
that arc through something that is brand
new that we're experimenting on
in the laboratory and you'll also know
that the people who don't have that kind
of access
are like your neighbor or your your
mayor or your governor unless they
themselves are listening
to the medical experts who are plugged
in to that
flow of research and so
so when they say oh sciences you should
think this and now they think this
therefore i'm not going to believe any
of it no that's not how this works
that's not how we got to the
civilization that we have today
so it means teaching science in a
slightly different way
to understand that is a way of arriving
at what is objectively true
in the world and then you get them early
on and then when they become mayors some
of the students of these
teachers are going to become mayors uh
very powerful people
heads of captains of industry and the
like they will then have this
understanding so that um
they'd be in a position to try to
convince an electorate
that if they're angry and you want to
take off your mask that has consequences
that we have researched and the
consequences you don't want because it
could make it worse
later and so that's that's what i got to
say
all right man let me calm down now that
it's very passionate i
i really enjoyed your uh i enjoyed it
you know what i mean all right very cool
all right so this is amanda and amanda
and
uh amanda watson wants to know this
i'm in my 30s do you think we will
colonize mars
uh uh or the moon in my lifetime
okay and then amanda phillips says what
are some of the space related activities
that can be done with preschool students
via long-distance
learning so wow okay so
uh so there's two different amounts
doubling up on you two different amandas
two different amanda's okay uh so
uh so again that one was the first one
was
what colonizing the moon and mars she's
in her 30s in her lifetime so
let's say she live let's say she'll live
to 130. okay
back in the day like 50 years ago 100
years ago
uh people imagined we would never get to
the moon because of how hard the task
was or
what challenges it would uh bring upon
us
and then we got to the moon and then
people's attitude towards such
achievements
shifted it actually did 180. and people
say oh we went to the moon now let's go
to mars
right no longer were there people saying
what was or was not
possible because we did the impossible
so i will now tell you
i think not in your lifetime will we
colonize either the moon or mars
because not because we don't know how to
do it
not because we couldn't figure out how
to do it but because i don't see the
motivation
to be there yeah you can want to do it
but at some point somebody's got to
write the check
somebody's got to sign the check and
what is their motivation to do it is it
just all let's just do it
no there's going to be you know what
drives it power drives it
military dominance drives it economics
the prospect of making money drives with
the great drivers in the history of
civilization
and so great as in the the most powerful
drivers i'm not value judging it i'm
just stating it so
uh if we colonize mars it would be
because there was a geopolitical reason
to do so
and then eventually yeah maybe you can
make a buck off of it you send tourists
there
this sort of thing you have a lottery
ticket and
you can imagine scenarios where you can
start making money on this
but i've said many times there are other
ways to make money in space
go mine an asteroid for its natural
resources
and the first trillionaire ever will be
the first person who exploits the
natural resources of asteroids
so it's not like space couldn't be an
excellent frontier but to colonize
you want to actually go to the moon and
live there
you want to go to mars and live there do
you know that
antarctica is warmer
and wetter than any place
on mars yet i don't see people lining up
to go buy condos on in antarctica
so you have to just factor all this in
i can i can imagine an outpost that you
go and
vacation there for a week i can say i
was on the moon for a week
that'd be but to live there and that'd
be your only place i don't
see that i don't feel that happening so
maybe tourist trips to the moon
in your lifetime so there you go
there'll be no no colony but there will
be airbnb
there we go and and maybe even
restaurants but they probably have no
atmosphere
oh
you have to throw that one in oh you did
it to me man you did it to me
okay now also do you have a space do you
have a space related activity
that could be done with a preschooler
yeah so
it's not about going into space but at
least about thinking about what's
happening over your head
with preschoolers get him to notice the
moon
and what and have him draw the phase of
the moon tonight okay
and then tomorrow have him draw the moon
again and then the next day have them
draw the moon again and they will see
the
shape of the moon is changing it changes
and by the way if you go back at the
same time to draw the moon
it's not in the same place it's in a
different part of the sky
oh my gosh it moved oh and so then you
learn the moon orbits the earth
and and you can do experiments in a
classroom
you turn out the lights close the blinds
and get a flashlight and you get an orb
and have kids all observe the orb when
the flashlight is illuminated from the
side
it's going to be a half lit orb it's
like a half moon
and then as you change your angle you
can see the crescent
you can see the full if the light is
from the other side and so
you can start thinking about the
machinery
of the solar system in that way and the
moon makes a great target for this
because it's a nice long project it
takes a full month
and kids can think about it and then you
do the experiment
in the classroom that works for
preschool right on up
so when do you tell them that the moon
is made of cheese when
when do you save that for for the very
end
good answer man that's a dare go a good
answer
all right um this is amy uh monahan from
uh
deland uh dalens she says um for
beginning stargazers what do you
recommend
to start so i'm a young neil degrasse
tyson what do i need to get into
stargazing okay first
a pair a good binoculars which is not
all that expensive
i haven't checked lately but i think you
can get a pair between 50
and 100 dollars and if that feels like a
lot of money consider that you buy it
once in your life
and so just amortize that over between
when you buy it and when you die
and ask what does that cost per year
relative to other things you consume
daily so that's how you need to think
about that purchase
i still have binoculars today that i
used 40 years ago because i'm that old
right so the binoculars are that good
wonderful well yeah
both and so with a good pair of
binoculars what's good about it is
they're good at night you can see the
moon and the craters and the
phases you can um uh if
depending on how good they are the upper
end of that you can see the rings of
saturn and the moons of jupiter
you can see that venus goes through
phases like the moon does this freaked
out galileo didn't freak him out he said
wait that means venus is going around
the sun not just around the earth
for it to go around the sun to go
through phases so that meant something
else was going on
than what everyone was teaching you in
the day
so and binoculars are great for sporting
events and for
bird watching and the rest of that so
start with binoculars
and a plus they're easy to sort of hand
off to other people hey take a look at
this what do you think of that
and so start there and then uh there are
stargazing books
that can help you identify oh sorry
books we have
apps now in my day we had to remember
what the constellations look like now we
have apps
where you hold up your smartphone to the
sky and it knows which direction you're
pointing and what's behind it
and it shows you the object and you can
tap on what everything is so
uh almost all the sky gazing apps
do that and because they have your
coordinate they know where you are
at all times but you can even point it
into the ground
and it tells you about the sky that you
can't see that hasn't risen yet
and so it's really good and that way you
can sort of work your way in
to these uh to what the scot what your
relationship can be with the night sky
and as always visit your local
planetarium right of course
that in there yeah exactly yeah you had
to do that you get paid to say that
we've got to take a break but more of
cosmic queries with pocket lab
when star talk returns
welcome back to star talk we're in the
middle of cosmic
queries with pocket land so
let's jump right back in all right all
right
uh let's do anna victoria um
um and anna victoria perez leon
wants to know this
how do we need to modify our approach
to learning now that students
have so much more information
yet less guidance
so i love this question and i
you know i'm going to expand this
question from anna victoria just a
little bit wider
we live in an age of information now
information is everywhere period
not just for children but for everybody
how are you
able to process this information in such
a way
that you're able to separate the wheat
from the chaff
okay uh that needs to be a new part of
the educational
curriculum which is assessing
the reliability of your sources and your
references
that was less necessary long ago there
was still
some garbage out there some the chaff i
get
yeah the chaff is the bad stuff you
don't want there was still some chaff
out there
but if you read a book it had to it went
through a manuscript phase that got read
by an
editor then a publisher invests in it
and then so there are multiple
filters that boosted the
chance that what ended up in book form
had some integrity to it
some academic authority and integrity to
it the pedigree of the author
would factor into this today since
anybody can post
anything on the internet at any time
anywhere
you don't have that built-in filter to
the system
and so i don't know that the wheat has
increased yes it surely has
but what has definitely increased is the
chaff
and i once tweeted just if you google
earth and you see pictures around earth
i said the google flat earth and they're
pictures of a flatter there's a whole
wiki page on the flat earth
google donut earth it's a donut
delicious i want to live longer i want
to live on donut earth
i'm sorry so the fact that you can type
these into a google search
and each one of them gives you an entire
wiki page describing
that belief system and if you don't
otherwise know if you're just an alien
who landed here
well you would know earth was around
plus you had the technology to figure
that out so not including aliens
talk about if you're just born into this
if you if you were in a
in a closet and you just came out and
you're trying to understand the world
you would not know which of these to
select so
again i got to put the burden back on
school teachers somewhere in there
you need to teach students how to
prioritize
the sources of their information and the
likelihood that something
is true or is simply fulfilling
a a political cultural social religious
agenda
in ways that then will mask what is
otherwise objectively true about the
world
and no you there's no guarantees here
but you can
boost the chances that what it is you
see think and do
are connected to an objective reality
and and and i as i've said
many times a search engine is the
ideal way to confirm
any belief you have no matter
what that belief is all right so if you
want to say
you know say but come up with anything
you type it in it goes
through the world and it finds any other
people who
think the same way as you do and then
you get this
false sense that your thoughts are
legitimate
because somebody else thinks it not be
and
this so that's a problem that needs to
be addressed and i think you have to
address it in the schools
it should be part of the curriculum
squeeze it in
push something else out i don't care how
you do it but
it could be the un the unraveling of
civilization
if people just say oh i don't want to
vaccinate my kids because
look and they type something in and out
comes some gibberish about
what vaccine people think what vaccines
do you other than
prevent you from getting a virus so
you're getting
fed information that that is not
authentic
nor in your best interest but you think
it is
and that's the problem cool
that's good stuff i i got to tell you
i'm
i'm still stuck on thinking about really
stupid aliens that land here and think
the earth is flat
they have to come from space and yeah
they'd have to actually see it and
they're
it could be a hologram i don't know
all right here we go here we go would
that be cool if aliens spoke like that
yeah hey what are you talking about
who took the wrong turn at alpha century
oh god here we go those are aliens from
brooklyn that's what i was gonna
say only in new york when we come up
with brooklyn aliens
all right here we go uh this is anne
leblanc or leblanc
from um from dartmouth
dartmouth new hampshire sure like excuse
me unless there's a dartmouth uk i don't
know
but all right we were not very creative
when we came to the new england new
england yeah
everything they named it after
everything else that they came from new
england
right right new canaan knew this knew
that new
you know well this is new york it's been
new amsterdam
yeah yeah yeah just can't you think up
another name
old explorer people very disappointed
plus how new is new york we it's you
know
what we should call us york and the
other one old europe
that's what we should have said right
there you go um this is what am wants to
know how do we explain the magnitude of
space to a child sitting in front of a
computer
wow that's a that's wow
ooh okay so there's some fun youtube
videos that do
zoom out from starting on earth and
going to the edge of the universe and
then coming back
and in fact the american museum of
natural history which is my
day job um uh we produced something
called the known universe
it's got like a zillion views on youtube
and give it to them and give it in full
screen and if you do one of those things
we can put it on a flat panel screen on
the wall
so it becomes almost cinematic rather
than just looking in a small screen
that is a zoom unnarrated just
visual trip from earth to the edge of
the universe and back and you get a
sense of the immensity of it all as
earth shrinks to this dot
as as as the solar system shrinks to a
dot
as our entire stellar neighborhood as
our galaxy
containing 100 billion stars shrinks to
a dot
in the distance so that that'll put him
in that'll that'll set him straight
right yeah
there you go that's a cool thing we did
a uh on the tv show we did a bit
um where we started it was like one of
those powers of tens videos where we
started at the edge of the universe
and we kept zooming in until we saw neil
degrasse tyson laying on a lawn
and then we zoomed into his mustache and
there was a whole nother universe
i remember that yeah it was pretty funny
all right here we go the jig is up
exactly right okay um
what else let's go let's go what's the
most important this is from clifton uh
roosevelt from mountain view not
uh uh clifton says this what is the most
important
astrophysics concept for
everyone to know oh yeah no that
i got this got this okay okay it is
um you need to know the
immensity of space
which you would get in one of these zoom
videos i mean zoom out
not not the the right but not that's not
what we're doing right now
where we're doing that exactly the
immensity of space
and the immensity of time
and i think those two are some of the
hardest
to grasp and people don't
really comprehend a million years
a billion years they can't wrap their
head around it
and so for me those it's not
understand a black hole those are just
objects that you can explain and learn
i'm talking about concepts and once you
get those concepts and you embed these
objects
in those concepts then you have a true
cosmic perspective
of who and what we are here on earth
there are people who are in denial of
evolution because they say
how can a single cell become a human
being with a brain and everything
because they don't understand how much
time has elapsed they can't comprehend
that you think they're thinking well i
don't see it happen
because it's happening longer than your
lifetime
longer than 100 of your lifetimes and so
you at the geologic how the rivers cut
mountains and glaciers cut that takes
time
and if you sped things up uh to a time
scale that's longer than
human life you'll get to see things
happen if volcanoes would come up and
down they'd repave that
you get an earthquake they get
subduction of the the continents
all of this would be going on like it's
a daily thing it just takes way longer
than your lifetime
to see it know it and embrace it they
used to call it
deep time and yes time is
older than the history of human
civilization
and that's a concept that needs to come
across wow
well i don't know why uh i'm depressed
now
but
there's an award-winning short film and
forgive i think it's called the wheel
it's a german film very short it's like
six minutes or eight minutes
i think it's called the wheel but i to
me i just call it the rock
rocks rocks and what it is it's a
conversation between two rocks
oh cool okay and
um things are happening in the
background i say what is that what is
that
what is that um you know the sky is like
pulsing in light
and then you realize those are days
going by
right that's funny so this is like
the world as seen by rocks and one rock
says oh do you do you have a problem
with lichens they i got itchy on the
back of my neck here
it takes a long time for lichens to
start eating away at rocks
but to them it's like it's their
lifespan and
they're spending their whole time and
they see trees come up and down and
volcanoes and all this
and then civilization shows up and then
a road goes by it gets built like
instantly
in their reference frame and then all
the civilization goes away
and they're still there that's cool
so you know civilization the time of
civilization relative to rocks
is very very short yeah yeah so fine i
think it's on youtube somewhere
the week
they find a wheel and they wonder about
it um that the cavemen had just invented
a wheel
and they're admiring it but then it just
sort of dissolves in their hands because
time moves quickly for them but um
anyhow check it out that's a sense of
trying to get a grasp
on time scales and what effect that
would have when you finally
uh appreciate it and recognize what role
it plays
in trying to understand who and what we
are in this world excellent
all right let's move on to dawn ritz and
dawn ritz is from san diego california
and she
says uh what would be a place in space
that you would take a science class and
why i love that that's a great question
i
love that so what's your space field
trip for the class
oh okay is it does it have to be a real
trip
or a trip that i'm imagining let me just
imagine
i would take a trip and we would go and
ride
alongside a comet and you'd start from
the outer solar system
and it's just to be this frozen ball and
as we get near the sun
the heat from the sun evaporates the the
the frozen ice the ice like the the
correct word there is
it sublimates because it'll go straight
from ice to gas
you'll see the tail grow as you come
closer into the sun
the inner planets begin to reveal
themselves you'll see
jupiter and then this asteroid belt and
then
mars and then earth and venus and and
mercury and
then you zoom around the back side of
the sun you come out the other side so
you get a tour of the solar system you
learn about comets you get to see all
the planets
and that would be my field trip wow
except they take
um to get a full trip there takes uh
depending on which comet you ride
would take a few decades so the kids
will be really old by the time it's done
but
it
otherwise you just put them in orbit and
take a few orbits around the earth
and you see earth from above and you see
like lightning storms and aurora
and you'll see 18 sunrises in one
24-hour period
um because that's how quickly an orbit
takes you
around so that would be you get the
overview effect which these
astronauts get where you see the earth
not
as the color-coded ball
uh color-coded globe in your social
studies class
you see it with no boundaries at all
it's oceans and land and clouds and and
that changes you
and it's called the overview effect it's
which is a version of the cosmic
perspective which we all need if we
don't otherwise have it there you go
all right let's go to emily gonzalez
from from moose creek and she wants to
know where's moose creek how
would i know okay
okay okay i'm sitting here in hoboken
hoboken new jersey the uh a lot of
creeks in michigan
yeah maybe it's in michigan i don't know
okay go on so um
and it's again it's gotta be a place
that has moose right so you gotta be
like that gotta be yeah
exactly it could be alaska i don't know
okay but go on
okay so she says um
she says how should i be tying my
love of all things space into my english
class
a little cross a little
cross-disciplinary love going on across
pollination
yes uh so hmm
okay uh there's some literature that
actually makes
interesting mention of space so for
example
in kirk vonnegut's novel slaughterhouse
five
uh that uh it involves uh cleanup
efforts
in dresden after the bombing of dresden
in the second world war
okay fine but the rest of the book
folded into that
is the encounter that the protagonist
has with space aliens
and he has access to the fourth
dimension in doing so
where he sees his entire life all at
once
he's always being born he's always dying
he's always living
it out in between manhattan
for example and from from watchmen
and so he uh so the aliens give him this
perspective
but the cost of that is they put him in
a in a zoo
for the other aliens to see the earth
creature that's there
but but because he's not bound in
time it doesn't matter that he's in the
zoo cage because he can just go to
anywhere else in his life
that he has lived so so there's stories
such as this you can read war of the
worlds
which involves invading space zones this
is classic literature
written of course by h.d wells um you
can be time machine
once again by h.g wells it's literature
you know does all literature have to be
faulkner and
and hemingway no there's other
literature written by great
writers who and forgive me i know only
primarily the english um writer uh
english language writers there's surely
others in other languages
i'm just saying that you can tap these
stories and then analyze them for
their create their scientific creativity
and
those writers are brilliant uh uh that
brilliant command of the english
language
so you can definitely fold these lessons
in so so that's what i'd recommend
okay so i'm trying to get as many in
here
first of all we got to stop uh asking
teachers for questions because
first of all teachers have great
questions
secondly you can't it's so difficult to
choose
which question you should ask because
like
they really are thoughtful
thank you guys for being on it we've got
to take another quick break but when we
return
i will introduce to you one of the
co-founders of pocket lab
welcome back to star talk we're in the
middle of a live
cosmic aquarius in collaboration with
pocket lab
and for this last segment i want to
bring on one of the founders of pocket
lab
dave baker check it out all right dave
just showed it i see dave dave's popped
in so i guess we're done
we're gonna wrap up and we're gonna do
more q a all right okay
you guys are right all the teachers on
we got thousands of questions
literally we sent them to
the start talk team and it's a stack of
paper i appreciate everybody's
perseverance
if you got your question answered you're
lucky dave let me just say this to
all the teachers many of you think very
much alike if i didn't ask
your question i didn't pick one person's
question
over another it's just that for every
question i read there were maybe
25 other teachers who asked a version or
similar version
of the same question so thank you guys
all right so dave you got some questions
yeah it was great just a couple of
things
i love kurt vonnegut there's one of my
favorite novels i think it was billy
pilgrim was the protagonist
yeah billy pilgrim that was the name of
the protagonist in slaughterhouse five
that's fine yeah that's my favorite the
other thing i wanted to mention you were
talking before about
being able to discern truth from
fiction um my eldest daughter went to uw
but by the way just not to be nitpicky
but i do not hold the word fiction as an
opposite word to the word truth
yeah okay if there's something true and
this otherwise
false fiction is a different
thing okay it's a different we're
communicating
ideas and stories and you're not while
you're reading these stories saying
that's not true that's not true that's
false no you're saying
there are lessons here to be gleaned
even though the character does not exist
even though this the the storyline has
never occurred
so they say fact or fiction i want to
reserve the word fiction
for its own genre rather than thinking
of it as the opposite of
what is fact well you'll be glad to know
so i feel the same way about the word
myth
is it true or is it myth you know myths
are stories
they're like as i described for the word
fiction they're stories of great tales
that have deep insights that offer deep
insights into our lives
i don't want to think of myth as
something that's just not true
it doesn't matter that a myth is not
true if it otherwise has great value to
us
so just use the word false is it true or
is it false
rather that is it true or is it myth
okay so that's my that's my two cents
this is great that's interesting well
smiths are important right um
yeah you know um at you my eldest
daughter went to uw they actually have a
class
uh uw university of washington yes
university of washington go huskies
and uh it the the class is called
calling bs and the age of big data
nice so we need that in elementary
school yes yes
and then you call it uh calling baloney
sandwich in the age
[Laughter]
how do you spot the baloney sandwiches
yes that's right
so i got a couple questions for you um
you know one thing i was thinking about
you know teachers we're
all of us teachers especially are being
forced to learn a new skill
and that's you know video conferencing
we
work on video conference we organize we
teach we communicate we meet new people
and it's been a struggle right and i
think there's been a lot of stress
but is is there maybe a silver lining is
this like a tool
that we're gonna have in our toolbox
that years from now we're gonna look
back and say
remember that the covid pandemic good
thing we learned video conferences
it turns out it's really useful um yes
okay next question okay
no i let me offer some reflections on
this first
yes the silver lining of all this zoom
calling and
and and otherwise video chatting
is and i'm gonna answer this from the
point of view
of an astrophysicist okay what it has
done is i don't know if you
if you've ever thought about this but
any time you've ever met
someone for lunch or for dinner or to
you you would say okay i'll meet you at
10 o'clock
well that's insufficient information to
actually meet them because you have to
then give
a location built into our lives
and our social uh discourse
is communicating a time and a place
this is the space-time coordinate system
that einstein tells us about
we live in space and we live in time
and you will only meet that person if
you are in the same place
at the same time that's why you can't
give just one of those and have it be a
successful meeting
i can't tell you i'll meet you at corner
of fifth avenue and 45th street
when okay well again make sure at
2pm where all right what
what video conferencing made for the
masses has done
it has separated those two coordinates
so now the where does it matter
because the wear is now distributed into
everyone's computer
and all that matters is the when
and as a result in this coronavirus
lockdown i have attended more science
seminars than i ever did in the last
five years
because i can't always be in the
department when the
my colleague is speaking because i'm on
tour or i'm in this i'm dead
and i but now it's it's a 45 minute
thing i've got time on my let me dial in
and so so the zooming as distance as we
are from each other
in fact the silver lining is that we've
never been closer simply because
we can communicate in ways that we care
about with body language with gestures
with oh where's yeah oh show me what
you've got in the kitchen or you carry
around the device
so we are by being more distant from
each other
there's a part of it that actually makes
us closer together
and if we carry that forward out of the
coronavers
uh it it's definitely another key
tool that i think teachers can use and
invoke
to deliver content and instruction
and and whatever else is necessary
to get the job done so that's how i
think about it yeah
it's great you know a great example uh
chuck and i never met in person but you
know we were working on this project
we we know a lot about each other and
and we made a ton of progress we
we didn't have to meet i would love to
go and have a drink with chuck but
you know we just can't right now and you
know it's it's okay
it's not great but it's fine it's
working
don't worry dave i have a i have a mask
with a hole in it and straws
we could both get permission from right
so chuck this is great you know another
another thing i'd love to have your
thoughts on
we have thousands of science teachers
here and
you know with this in the last
conference we're gonna do a ton of these
we have tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of science
teachers
have you ever thought is there like if
if you could have a goal
if we could all organize and get
together and have a single
mind as science educators and
set like a five year or ten year goal to
really
change education and change the next
generation of
young students what like what would be
like the top couple things that
would be worth focusing this brings us
that's a great question and it brings us
full circle back to the was it the very
first question that chuck
pulled up which is um
i think it's too short-sighted to say
here's what we should do
and here's what you should know because
that could change
that might need modification that might
need to be
uh adjusted based on culture
politics whatever are the forces
operating
budget whatever the force is operating
at the time but
if you instilled
successfully instilled a sense of
curiosity curiosity
aiming to find out what is objectively
true
that is something you carry for your
lifetime
that's something you carry into every
room you step
into every conversation you have no
matter
how powerful the person is with whom you
have that conversation
being curious about what is objectively
true
enables you to navigate a path of
inquiry
to arrive at that true truth and almost
anybody enjoys that journey you know i
think people
if you can say well let's think about it
this way i never thought about that well
that's true then this could be true
let's check that
and you just navigate this together and
then you arrive
at sensible wise conclusions together
so this is a tool that
students need to have so so as teachers
especially as science teachers
except there was one english teacher out
there who asked about the novels
totally welcome you there but especially
as science teachers
who are the keepers of the the
the the of of the search for what is
objectively true in the natural world
that those tactics are what matters
here okay and let's go to the the the
the the social sciences and the and the
liberal arts
where you do a research on on a research
topic
on a paper right you write a paper i
guess they still do that in high school
maybe not in elementary school but
there's a topic you don't know much
about how are you going to research it
what are your sources how are you going
to trust those sources
what conclusions will you draw based on
this this is all analysis
and not enough in the school system
is about analysis it's all about
knowledge like you're some kind of empty
vessel fill it with knowledge and now
you're done
let's process you and send you on your
way i'd rather you started out as an
empty vessel and ended as an empty
vessel
except you had a toolkit around you
to feed that vessel with whatever you
encounter
later on and and know how to establish
what is objectively true in what it is
you have investigated once you've done
that
you won't have any of this you don't
that you you won't have flat earthers
you won't have vaccine deniers you won't
have climate deniers
because they would have understood what
the path is to find out what is
objectively true
and and they will know the risk of their
bias
cultural political social bias
influencing what it is they're thinking
and to be scientifically literate is to
have
this fluency in inquiry
knowing how to ask questions and knowing
when you have arrived at an answer that
has sufficient data
to support your conclusions so i've
always said to be scientifically
literate
is to be inoculated against charlatans
who are out there
against people who think they know what
they're talking about
but in fact don't because the biggest
challenge we have
just as a species as individuals
is is thinking i've said this before
thinking
you know enough about something to
knowing enough about something to think
you're right
but not enough about that same thing to
know that you're wrong
there's this like there's this valley in
there and there are a lot of people that
are sitting in that valley
who don't know enough to know that
they're wrong but know just enough to
think that they're right
and if those people ever rise to power
and if they do and when they
it's dangerous like i said it's like
unraveling
it's too late too late neil you're too
late
sorry buddy yeah so this these are my
these are my words of wisdom in whatever
way they can land
um among among the teachers out there i
think that's faint
i think that's a goal i think that's
something to think about is you remind
me i
had a great mentor in my life who always
told me you have to invest in yourself
and your education
because no matter what happens in your
life nobody can take that from you
yes that's correct that's right it's
it's it becomes part of
who you are and what you bring to every
next encounter and challenge
that life delivers and i wanna if i can
and i know we gotta be running long i
wanna
end with one sort of something about
which i feel strongly
okay every teacher
tuned in right now was once a student
okay we were all students at some level
of the educational pipeline
as a student we all
had some great teachers and we had some
crappy teachers
okay and we remember them
for being great and we remember them for
being crappy
okay and those teachers who were great
they you just enjoyed being
in their classroom they had an
enthusiasm an expertise
a a uh a a a
a command of the content where you just
wanted to bask
in their brilliance and it wouldn't
matter what the subject was
you can have a favorite subject over
here but they're a great teacher in this
other subject
they make that's your favorite subject
that semester you know
you had those teachers and by the way
how many of those teachers did you have
i've done i've done this exercise okay
i've been in a room with thousands of
people i say
how many truly great teachers have you
had in your life
most people it's like it fits on one
hand maybe three
five it tops most people it's two to
two and some of them it's just one and i
say to myself
this is out of scores of teachers in
some cases hundreds if you went through
college and graduate school there's only
this many well those are the super
teachers so here's my challenge
to every teacher tuned in right now
be that super teacher that you
know you had as a student
be that teacher and if you do if you
become
that teacher you might already be that
teacher don't i don't
you know i don't want to call out stuff
that doesn't need to be called out
but we know as students as having been
students
who these great teachers are become
those super teachers
and if you do you will transform the
school system overnight
yeah that's great and you know i tell
you something
about the audience who comes to these i
think a lot of them are those super
teachers but that's why they're here
this is the summer you know you're
supposed to be on vacation what do you
do you're going to spend all day
uh listening to us let's be right it
means you're committed
you commit admitted yeah so it's
fantastic
neil those are great words to end with
chuck thank you so much
you guys we're fantastic um the chat is
going by they're going crazy
okay thanks god we've got to wrap it up
here but
thanks for tuning in to this special
edition of cosmic queries
in collaboration with pocket lab and i
want to
thank pocket lab and their organizers
and all the teachers
who participated in this live cosmic
queries
and as always i bid you to keep looking
[Music]
up